c'est le rassemblement de la dernière
chance puisque depuis ce matin la
direction et les syndicats discutent de
ce plan social avec un enjeu
considérable pour les syndicats
puisqu'il s'agit de sauver 8 131 postes
sur ce site
à noter dans l'essonne alors les
salariés se disent écoeurés par ce plan
social d'autant plus qu'ils se sont
énormément investis pendant le
confinement pour ne pas réduire la
production sur ce site et pour ne pas
ralentir l'activité alors parmi les
postes menacés aussi bien des
techniciens que des ingénieurs qui ne
comprennent pas cette décision de nokia
alors que le secteur de la téléphonie
mobile est en plein essor écoutez bien
aujourd'hui nous sommes donc là pour
soutenir les camarades salariés de
l'entreprise nokia qui vient de leur
annoncer encore une fois un nouveau plan
social
un nouveau plan de suppression de
l'emploi plan de sauvegarde même
suppressions d'emplois évidemment à
nouveau puisque le dernier a eu lieu il
ya un an et demi maintenant
donc voilà on est là pour soutenir et
porter l'idée que voilà on doit pouvoir
faire autrement dans la période sur le q
à quoi nous faisons de nos compétences
parce que les collègues qui en deux ans
commençait déjà avec le 2g notre avis
sur le 3g et 4g nous aimons et
comprenons combien ça et non en fait on
peut annuler par trouver dans le monde
mais on veut nous allons remplacer un
pas deux pas des autres pour les maisons
neuves
tous les prétextes faire des économies
on peut faire des économies mais on leur
dit inondé la qualité deux semaines
avant d'annoncer son plan avait fait une
réunion du contenu du de ce qu'on
appelle la commission économique est là
n'avait pas parlé de problèmes
économiques donc deux semaines après
trouver un problème économique indienne
commission dédiée pour ça ou l'employeur
est censé communiquer de façon honnête
sincère et complète
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de son côté
le groupe finlandais explique que ce
plan social fait partie d'un plan
mondial de réduction des coûts lancés
fin 2018 pour disent ils rester
compétitif à long terme